لم يتبق سوى القليل من الضوء
لأكراد سوريا الذين يجب أن يدفنوا موتاهم
وولاءاتهم القديمة ، لم يحن الوقت
لكي تموت ابني ،
لماذا قُتلت
.  لقد حزنوا مثل هذا من قبل
بتوجيهات أمريكية لقتال داعش
ودفنوا 10000 من الأبناء والبنات الآن
أطلق رؤساء أمريكا في مكالمة هاتفية واحدة العنان
لجيش الناتو والقوات الجوية التركية عليهم
، وتركهم الجيش الأمريكي على مضض
شهيدًا لا يموت انظر
فرصة  واحد من كثيرين هنا لا
يبدو أنهم سيقدمون إلى حدود تركيا الجديدة
قريبًا في المستشفى في
القامشلي ، يصطف الأطباء في الخارج
لاستقبال الجرحى ، إنه تدفق لا نهاية له
على الرغم من أكثر من أسبوع من قتال
المقاتلين الأكراد السوريين الذين اشتكوا كثيرًا
نظرًا لوجود بنادق كلاشينكوف قديمة فقط
لمحاربة داعش ، لا يزالون يحتفظون بالأتراك
، فقد حصلوا على بعض المساعدة
اليائسة بما يكفي لعقد صفقة مع
شيء أسوأ من ذلك  في شيطان
وصول النظام السوري إلى هنا في أقصى
الشمال تمامًا في بلدة التاميل ، قد تكون الأعلام
جديدة جدًا لدرجة أنها تم الكشف عنها للتو ،
لكن التحركات التي يظهر فيها الولاء قديمة
وتمارس حتى العام.
الأكشاك في
أنقرة وقريبًا الكرملين
والملاجئ النازحين ، ومرة أخرى ، رب
ا يكون مئات الآلاف في حا
ة تحرك مع اس
مرار القتال.  النظام الداعم في مكان قريب
أخبر تمارا الموالية أن القوات التركية توغلت
في هذا الطريق والقاعدة الأمريكية
الغربية مع النظام وروسيا الآن
في منبج مما أدى إلى
تصادم الجانبين في مدينة كوباني
وظهر فيديو ليلة الأربعاء
عن لحظة رمزية عميقة للنظام السوري
بدخول القوات إلى مدينة كوباني
حيث قاتل الأكراد السوريون منذ شهور
بدعم جوي أمريكي لطرد داعش
من تحت الأنقاض لكننا الآن روسيا
والعودة.  gime هناك حماة جدد من
معجزات الناتو